my friend wayne sent me this article
and i immediately read it and thought i
can't believe i haven't
thought of this because i say some of
these things
but then i thought oh gosh i may be
wrong and so i need to make sure
that i'm not an idiot and so
um and those aren't mutually exclusive
here so
i'm just going to read you a couple of
things it's an article by a guy named
pete ross now listen i don't know
anything about pete i never met pete i
don't
know pete um and so pete may be the
worst guy ever
i don't think so he's probably a great
guy too he may be just fine
i don't know pete ross so partridge in a
pear tree
but here's what um the article talks
about and it's
fascinating uh just a quick quick
snippets
in 2020 outrage is the latest drug of
society
it's more acceptable than alcohol it's
more addictive than anything you can
swallow smoke or inject because while
heroin and meth are clearly harmful
anger feels so righteous after all
it's the other political party that's
ruining the world their supporters hate
america
people are too selfish we're not doing
enough for the poor we're not doing
enough for the one percent women don't
have enough rights men don't have enough
rights those people are racist though
that group doesn't even recognize their
privilege
and on and on and he goes to write we
love being angry because it makes us
feel
smart that reminds me of an article that
a guy named dr stoney wrote in
psychology today
i think this year two ago anger
we blame somebody when we get angry
because it sets off our adrenaline
and we have to have adrenaline for a
fight or flight and you can become
addicted to that
anger when you get angry it makes you
feel
smart it makes you feel a little bit of
power which you need in a moment if
you're going to take off sprinting if
you're going to turn and fight a bear
and it tells us that we're the ones that
need to be in charge
right that we call someone out or worse
we try to ruin their careers because
they deserve it because i'm right
and and and an outrage
sells like crazy because it's a strong
emotion and strong emotions force people
into action
that's why political parties instead of
just solving problems
which nobody will do instead of solving
problems
they whip their supporters into a frenzy
i'm still reading here
whip their supporters into a frenzy of
anger against whatever other side is
corporations are now getting involved
they weaponize your outrage to sell
their products
now you all know my thoughts on
technology how they create these
ecosystems right and i'm a part of it i
get it too feel free to
pat move right on right but this is a
thought i hadn't considered before
now here's what he writes now rather
than get on my high horse and tell you
that you're being played for a fool
and you should stop participating in the
media blah blah blah i just want to ask
one question
how is this working out for you
has constantly reading liking retweeting
or commenting your outrage made your
life any
better has it helped any of the
injustices that you're actually trying
to fight
what's it actually doing for you has it
helped you earn more work
be better with your family has it made
you more fulfilled has it helped solve
the insanity of systemic racism and
poverty and hate and political divide
has it helped he writes my guess is it
just made you even more pissed off and
angry
so he ends it with here's a better idea
what if we use that time and energy to
actively better your life
and the lives of those around you
if you don't do that and keep being
outraged by everything your anger is
going to consume you
or if somebody says something outrageous
that you disagree with
don't give them smoke don't give them
the fire
simply go outside and serve somebody
simply go outside and join the march the
peaceful protest simply go outside and
invite someone to your house
who's hungry be about these solutions
not outraged by them now here's the
thing
he ends with this it's important to
remember that yes there are more
injustices than you can shake a
stick at you all know me well enough
there are so much disgust and evil and
ugliness out there
over and over and over and over
but thumbs downing something or mean
comments just simply aren't helping
if you want to take somebody's power
away take their voice away
just walk away because you know what if
the injustice machine i mean nothing
justice if the outrage machine doesn't
get the clicks they'll stop putting the
stories up
they'll stop it'll just end because
they're not getting anything
right so i
i hadn't thought of this idea that
outrage is ruining people's lives in
this direct way
and outrage is important when you see
something disgusting you gotta step up
and you gotta step
in but i don't know if media fights
media screaming is the way to do it
and i've gotten suckered into this the
last year especially through the
political season of
man going to war and being loud i've got
away from some of my core principles
with thought which are
i'm gonna love local i'm gonna take care
of people in my community and i'm gonna
go out of my way to make sure people are
are in my sphere are taken care of and i
hope
that when you feel anger rise up in you
and you recognize that it's pointing you
towards something you care about
that your solution is to go get involved
in care
face to face person to person heart to
heart
and not just to join the outrage parade
love that question it's from the old
american history x how is this
working out for you how is this making
your life better
it's a great question we should all ask
ourselves and more importantly how
should how is this helping
other people's lives those who are
suffering these injustices
all right wayne thanks for sending this
on man um it gives me something to think
about i'd love to hear your thoughts so
feel free to
email us back or shoot me on the
internets at john delony
you can follow me there